netflix is a genuine treasure trove when
it comes to movies
and many of the platform's original
productions are counted among the most
exciting releases of the last few years
here's a look
at the 10 most watched netflix original
movies
ranked according to their ratings on
rotten tomatoes
in 2019 a stunning 83 million viewers
tuned in to watch michael bay's
streaming debut six
underground the film's rotten tomatoes
stands at 36 percent
but critics weren't really the intended
audience to begin with and the score
actually places it squarely in the
middle of bay's filmography
review-wise so if you're a fan of the
director's trademark frenetic action
stylings this will be right up your
alley it's a crowd pleaser to be sure
the plot centers on an elite group of
mercenaries who have faked their own
deaths in order to carry out missions
off the grid their assignment travel to
the fictional land
of turgistan to replace the country's
brutal dictator with his imprisoned
brother
with its loud explosions snappy action
movie dialogue
in an unrelenting pace six underground
is without a doubt
a prime cut michael bay production and
if that sounds like your kind of thing
then you're bound to find it a whole
heap of fun
hollywood power partners mark wahlberg
and director peter berg have produced a
number of great movies
including lone survivor deepwater
horizon and patriots day sadly
spencer confidential didn't quite earn
the same rave reviews as those pictures
a 37 rotten tomato score didn't stop 85
million people from streaming this
throwback cop movie
making it one of the platform's biggest
ever hits the movie is an adaptation
of robert b parker's popular spencer
novels with wahlberg stepping into the
famous
detective's shoes spencer is a cop who
plays by his own rules which doesn't
play so well at a time
when police brutality is under
heightened scrutiny the script is
co-written by oscar winner brian
helgeland
and it gives wahlberg plenty of excuses
to kick ass with his partner
and cut it up with his wisecracking
buddy meanwhile a number of him using
cameos by famous faces
help liven things up between all the
action since it's based on just one book
in the spencer series
and considering the huge number of
people who watched it it's hard to
imagine
wahlberg won't holster up for a sequel
as the famous detective
sometime soon in 2014
adam sandler's happy madison productions
signed a lucrative deal with netflix
that has since produced some of the
comedians most widely viewed films
the most watched among them murder
mystery brought in 83
million viewers which in box office
terms would make it a financial success
on par with the waterboy it also earned
pretty good reviews
relative to most sandler comedies
earning a 44
score on rotten tomatoes the film
reunites sandler with his just go with
it co-star jennifer aniston and it
allows the sandman to vacation
in exotic locales with his best buds for
the cause of comedy
the movie script is sharp and sprightly
enough to keep everyone else as
entertained as the people who made it
the premise sandler and aniston are a
couple traveling through europe on their
15th wedding anniversary
on the plane they meet a mysterious
billionaire who invites them to party on
his yacht with his elderly uncle
while at sea however the uncle is found
killed with his own dagger
and sandler and aniston are the main
suspects audrey
yeah get the cocktail sauce released the
same year as sandler's critically
acclaimed uncut gems
murder mystery finds the actor in the
familiarly goofy territory lots of fans
want to see
from the funny man for that reason alone
it's perhaps no mystery why so many
people tuned in
george clooney's sci-fi epic the
midnight sky earned a 50
rotten tomato score critics noticed that
the movie has more than a few things
going for it
bringing in 72 million viewers and
earning an oscar nomination for its
visual effects
clooney stars as augustine a dying
scientist stranded on an
earth that has been ravaged by an unseen
disaster
left alone at a research facility in the
arctic he attempts to warn off any
spaceships on their way back to the
desolated planet
when he finds himself unable to reach
the incoming crew
of the ether augustine travels across
the frozen tundra to warn them
but the ship's crew are having a few
problems of their own the two halves of
the midnight sky
really come together in a third act
twist that links an
emotional through line between them
along with the story
the technical aspects of the film are
unarguably stunning with martin rua's
cinematography
to alexander display's heartbreaking
score
as the summer of 2020 dragged on it
became increasingly clear that the
pandemic would keep theaters closed
so naturally audiences increasingly
turned to streaming services to get
their blockbuster kicks
it's little wonder then that 75 million
people
watched the high concept action thriller
project power when it dropped on netflix
that august
the movie also netted a 61 rotten
tomatoes rating
in an era dominated by mainstream comic
book movies
project power imagines a stranger
scenario one in which
anyone can become a superhero by taking
an experimental drug
the catch the effects only last for five
minutes and there's no telling what
superpower you might gain
or whether you'll use it for good or
evil chaos predictably ensues
when the drug hits the streets of new
orleans so teenager robin teams up with
a local cop
and an ex-soldier to track down the evil
pharmaceutical company
who made it as the critics will tell you
the true power of this film comes from
its impressive performances
and thrilling action sequences and
there's still plenty of room to add more
to the intriguing story
in a sequel it seems like only yesterday
that the bird box challenge was sweeping
the nation
forcing netflix to issue a public plea
for people to stop walking around while
blindfolded
released during the holiday season of
2018
this movie does forsight what a quiet
place did for sound
and just like that horror hit bird box
was a sensation
bringing in a total of 89 million
viewers and a 63
rotten tomato score adapted from the
novel by josh malerman
the movie star sandra bullock as mallory
an expectant mother whose fears of
becoming apparent are quickly set aside
for an even greater terror
to reveal much more would spoil the
movie's fascinating premise
but it's probably fair to say that the
scene in which mallory and our children
make their way through the woods
is among the most iconic horror
sequences of the last few years
susannah bier creates a constant sense
of dread and tension
throughout birdbox relying on good
old-fashioned suspense and atmosphere
over flashy special effects she also
does a good job with her ensemble
eliciting performances that keep you
invested in the human story at the heart
of it all
with 99 million viewers extraction is
the most
watched film in netflix's history and
there's certainly a good reason for that
the film hit the streaming site in april
2020
just as the coronavirus pandemic was
forcing the closure of movie theaters
across
the country the movie earned a 67
approval rating on rotten tomatoes
and the high viewership was more than
enough to justify a sequel
and perhaps even a franchise directed by
sam hargrave from a script by joe russo
extraction has got all the trappings of
a whiz-bang action blockbuster
chris hemsworth stars as tyler rake a
mercenary tasked with rescuing the son
of an imprisoned indian crime lord who's
been kidnapped by his father's rivals
extractions action is its best quality
being masterfully directed by hargrave
who had previously worked as a stunt
coordinator on hemsworth's various
marvel cinematic universe films
he also makes the most out of the film's
r-rating
spilling blood by the bucket full and
bringing a real intensity to the film's
action sequences
what more could you want from a punchy
lockdown blockbuster
zack snyder dominated the streaming
services in early 2021
shortly after his four-hour director's
cut of justice league
hit hbo max the director released the
grizzly horror flick
army of the dead on netflix it didn't
take long for army of the dead to crack
the streamer's top 10 most viewed films
racking in a staggering 72 million
viewers
plus the movie's 68 rotten tomato score
places it in the top half
of snyder's filmography from a critical
standpoint considering snyder's first
film was a remake
of george a romero's dawn of the dead
it's only fitting that he would one day
return to the zombie genre
army of the dead is a sly hybrid of
horror and heist movies
following a mercenary who is tasked with
recovering 200 million dollars from a
casino vault in a zombie infested las
vegas
before the military nukes the city off
the map snyder seems to paint the screen
with blood in this movie
making the most of his hard r rating the
supporting cast helps liven things up
too
most notably tig notaro as one of lead
actor
dave bautista's gang of thieves 100
i'm in yeah you don't want to know you
know the risks or
why would i want to know the risks for
fans of snyder and his flashy
stylized type of movie it really doesn't
get much better than this
one of the surprise hits of the pandemic
summer was the old guard
which hit netflix in july 2020 all in
all
78 million viewers tuned in with
interest undoubtedly
peaked by the movie's sterling 80 score
on rotten tomatoes
charlize theron stars as andy the
immortal leader of an elite squad of
mercenaries
together with her brothers in arms andy
travels the globe protecting mortals and
along the way picks up a soldier who
discovers that she too
is unable to die in adapting writer greg
rucka
an artist leandro fernandez's graphic
novel
director gina prince by the wood infuses
the superhero
genre with the sublime passions of her
previous films
what's really special about the old
guard is the way in which prince by the
wood
so deftly balances the movie's more
emotional scenes with its action
sequences
those elements work in perfect harmony
with theron who brings plenty of
emotional heft to her performance
and once again proves herself to be an
apt action star
at a time when marvel and dc have taken
great pains to create interconnected
sagas
geared towards mass consumption the old
guard is proof that an original vision
can break through and find a mass
audience to boot
the netflix smash hit and nola homes
raked in 76 million viewers during the
fall
of 2020 it's also one of the platform's
most critically acclaimed titles
with a certified fresh 91 rotten
tomatoes rating
millie bobby brown plays enola holmes a
teenage sleuth who's following in the
footsteps of her famous older sibling
sherlock while sherlock is happy to
encourage her sleuthing her other
brother mycroft
thinks she'd be better placed learning
etiquette at finishing school
i don't want a husband and that is
another thing you need to have
educated out of you when her mother goes
missing however it's up to enola to
track her down
deciphering clues from a variety of
birthday presents she left behind
her investigation uncovers a vast
conspiracy
revolving around a young aristocrat
who's similarly trying to break free of
the societal restraints placed upon him
it's not difficult to see why this was
such a hit enola holmes is just
dangerous and droll enough to have some
real edge while providing teenage
viewers with an uplifting girl power
message
considering it's based on just one book
from nancy springer's popular young
adult series
it's also safe to say the adventures of
manola homes are far from finished
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one